while zielinski is talking about a
no-fly zone our own media is enforcing a
no-think Zone there will be no thinking
there will be no thinking in public
there will be no communication of
thoughts every conversation will be
turned towards white supremacy and
bigotry and it's time to clear these
idiots off the stage because right now
we've got a nuclear situation welcome
everybody to a quarterly update
with times man of the microsecond no no
this is this is perhaps one of the
greatest of all friends and neighbors it
is Eric Weinstein joining me today to
speak about the state of the Multiverse
Eric how are you doing good sir
great Brian how are you it's great to
see you I wish we were in person uh
we're gonna have to make that happen
it's been a it's been a month or two
it's a little too long it's not going
through Einstein withdrawal symptoms I
get the shakes and I might be mistaken
but there might be some news afoot in
your particular uh area of the
Multiverse why don't you share any news
that you'd like to share right up front
I think what's going on with me is that
uh
I'm trying to understand
why I'm perceiving a different situation
and a different planet than
the rest of my brethren I'm I feel like
we're being called to do very specific
things we're clearly not doing them
and a lot of this is being driven by the
accident if you will
of um
Vladimir Putin taking some initiative
in Eastern Europe my father you know of
blessed memories to go to bed every
night listening to Art Bell who is a
Titanic individual in the world of
broadcasting you may know of him you may
not he used to do like a 12-hour radio
show and then he'd sign off at three in
the morning and then he'd go on ham
radio
for like another eight this guy was a
was a Titan in the field anyway the
point that he would often bring up is
that the pace of humanity is
accelerating not the uh kurzweil-esque
Singularity but this sort of quickening
that news cycles that events that
Titanic shifts are occurring faster and
faster and ever more so after September
11th of course but I feel like it's
unsustainable I I feel like we cannot
get off uh of this cycle of just in
constant adrenaline hits uh so I was you
know in need of talking to you many
times in the last couple of months and I
know the audience was too but I'm gonna
mix I mean is it where do you see us
going let's let's just not bury the lead
are are we headed towards a incredibly
serious nuclear confrontation with a
with an armed nearly 70 year old
individual with a nearly 80 year old
individual at the Helm of the Free World
probably not but probably not means less
than 50 percent if I actually do the
math on this and no one can because it's
not a math problem
but metaphorically if I start to compile
the facts I would guess that we are
running
between one and five percent chance of a
nuclear Exchange
over no known ideology before this
Ukrainian Adventure uh has concluded one
thing that I've learned is that if the
odds aren't over 50 percent a giant
percentage of the population says well
it's unlikely all right they don't
weight it against what we're talking
about so you know for me I would like to
be able to whisper
I don't know maybe it's three percent
maybe it's five percent maybe it's one
percent
we're running some catastrophic risk
of having the Mahabharata box B minor
Mass all of the uh sporting events that
have ever been held with fantastic
outcome Bob Beeman's long jump
all of that being obliterated
by the choices of what I take to be five
relatively undistinguished human beings
and that would be Putin
Biden zielinsky G
and Kim in North Korea and I'm looking
at these people I mean this is to say
nothing of Iran or Modi in Indian but
just just the five people I named are
reevaluating the chess board the World
War II order has now broken
the invasion of Ukraine by Russia is
unprecedented in the 21st century and it
is very well precedented in the 20th the
thing that was holding everything
together is now broken
and we're living through something that
is akin to the Cuban Missile Crisis in
my estimation
but until all of the news outlets say
the odds are you know considerably north
of the odds during the Cuban Missile
Crisis no one's going to wake up now why
are the odds so high it's not capitalism
versus communism it's not Protestants
versus you know
Catholics it's not Hindus versus Muslims
it's
we got into a habit during peace time of
um just deciding that every time we
could expand NATO that was a great thing
and depending upon how you think about
that either it's a wonderful strategy
for
um you know really controlling Russia by
encircling it with allies of the West
or it's a provocation just the way we
would see it if it was happening in our
Hemisphere and somehow China was setting
up a base in Toronto or something like
that right although you know to push
back with respect on that when you look
at uh you know our territorial
aspirations it wasn't like you know we
were threatening Russia we weren't all
right we meaning Ukraine rather it
wasn't necessarily actively threatening
to invade Russia per se whereas you know
provocation on the Mexican you know
border with the United States or
Canadian border you know that is there's
what reason would it have other than
territorial expansion as proven in 2014
2013 and now in 2022. it's not it's not
like Putin hasn't he hasn't demonstrated
that he's willing to uh take have
territorial aspirations for what he
perceives as a benefit to him so I think
it would be somewhat different right
than just to say nato now uh you know or
Mexico now joins the Warsaw Pact which
doesn't exist but
I really don't know what to say Brian
a lot of us were very concerned about
what the reasoning was
um in extending
you know NATO status to Latvia
you know it's super close to Moscow and
it's like is it a thousand miles maybe
even inside there's a lens where you'd
get to say wow these are sovereign
states they get to do whatever they
choose to do who's to tell them that
sounds like paternalism you know
okay you're talking about the world I
mean I I just I can't shake this that
wasn't pushback that you just did we
know
Putin is a bad guy
I want us to win
I don't want to be unclear about that
we're talking about the world we're
talking about a a habitable world a
world in which we recognize buildings
from Antiquity where it's relatively
safe to breathe the air
I don't know what conversation we're
having I'm just very confused by it when
you have Article 5 status in NATO and
you've decide that you've got peacetime
careerists who want to burnish their
resumes by saying I'm the president who
extended NATO to more countries that
happened under my watch and you're not
really thinking about the idea this goes
back to Stephen pinker's idea that we're
living in the Most Blessed era of all
time right where and you know I'm having
the same issue over and over again with
the economist with price indices all of
these people
they look at certain terms in the
equation without looking at the whole
equation and then they decide I'm seeing
enough of the equation that I can draw
strong conclusions right and what we
have is a world saturated in potential
violence in the form of nuclear weapons
biological weapons fuel air weapons are
incredibly terrifying the weapons of
demoralization
that make you know why does Japan
capitulate at the end of World War II
the way it does is because somebody's
brought the fire of the sun to Japanese
soil
you know yeah you actually made a very
uh provocative statement but I think it
on further reflection has uh some Merit
to it which will probably shock most of
my listeners and that you were
advocating for the detonation of a of a
fusion device not a fission device at
some point in the past maybe it was 2019
uh to kind of reiterate and Shake the
Dust off of the complacency that uh that
were you you know looking into your you
know patented crystal ball back then and
and I mean what what was that based on
at that point because Eric we both know
you know this guy Lawrence Krauss he's
been a guest on my show and people like
Shelly glasshow a friend of the show as
well and they're on this thing called
the bulletin of the atomic scientists
and every day you know Trump woke up and
tweeted they were moving the the
secondhand Club do you feel like your
client are your uh you know kind of uh
proposal shall I say to do this was
really encounter to that kind of Cry
Wolf effect that they kept increasing it
over pet like the woman's March okay now
we need to move it up I mean was that in
response to that because it was way
before George Floyd it was way before
covid it was way before years look why
why why was that front of my mind for
you why was I on the twin nuclei problem
we just spent you know how many years
living indoors not attending our our
loved ones funerals with masks over our
faces having no idea whether they work
not really understanding what we're
injecting into our bodies I was warning
you about the twin nuclei problem have
we done that for people that might be
new to your thoughts sure in less than
six months between 1952 and 53 we
unlocked the secrets of the nucleus of
the cell in the form of
three-dimensional structure of DNA
followed by the genetic code 10 years
later
and we unlocked the ability to fuse
nuclei with the teller oolam device
and those I guess I of you Mike was our
first nuclear test in 52.
a fusion device first Fusion device
right and
those Innovations made humans capable of
their own extinction by just fiddling
around with power that we don't know how
to control we know how to unlock it
you know but we don't know how to
control it so if you give somebody
um a bottle of Jack Daniels a Ferrari
and a machine gun
um they can have a pretty interesting
time just getting to know their their
new friends I don't know what we're
doing I I'm so flipped out and I was
calling for a return to rare above
ground atmospheric nuclear tests because
I don't believe in their absence human
beings will actually do the computation
of what we're talking about we're having
the most irrelevant discussions
as long as Ukraine looks like um house
to house fighting and as long as
zelinski is telegenic and by the way you
know Bruce Willis is stepping away from
acting it's funny because I was saying
that zelenski you know is the ultimate
sort of Bruce Willis character when he's
offered uh you know the ability to
evacuate he says
I need ammunition
not a ride you know it's like wow uh
that that plays well because adios
mother
comrade comrade
we're crazy I I can't I can't go to
parties I was just at a party I was a
complete pill
um I I've been telling people if you
don't watch the cell and the atom you
can have all the Bitcoin conversations
you want all the conversations about
liquid democracy and institutional
reform and web three and it's just like
nobody's paying attention we are
sleepwalking to Armageddon and what I
learned from from the invasion of
Ukraine is that what I was trying to do
with my show was to wake people up
and Vladimir Putin just said hold my
beer
and everybody hit the snooze button I
mean we're talking about Ukraine it's
not like we're not talking about it but
we're talking about it
you know do we think Putin will
capitulate is he out of options we turn
everything into a soap opera right just
like do you want this guy cornered and
weak I certainly don't no and do you
want to talk about you know he cannot be
allowed to remain in power and then you
know Biden has to walk by well I didn't
mean regime change we've got children
I've got a 79 year old child
uh as the President of the United States
and then I did the computation it was
116 days where Harry Truman went from
the ceremonial role of Vice President of
the United States largely ceremonial
position
to being the one to drop two Atomic
devices on civilians and Military in
Hiroshima Nagasaki the person who
currently holds Harry Truman's old job
is Kamala Harris I'm not supposed to be
able to say anything about Kamala Harris
you mustn't say I have to stop you
because she's both female and uh a
person dark of hue and the answer is no
Kamal Harris isn't really fit for that
job and it's evident I don't need to go
into detail the idea that you can't even
speak in our society to say obvious
things like there's something weird
going on with women's swimming
uh or even answer what is a woman right
that became controversial last week
right so in essence the media in my
estimation and our Tech Giants are while
zelinski is talking about a no-fly zone
our own media is enforcing a no-think
Zone there will be no thinking there
will be no thinking in public there will
be no communication of thoughts every
conversation will be turned towards
white supremacy and bigotry and it's
time to clear these idiots off the stage
because right now we've got a nuclear
situation no I think I think you're
being abundantly clear and speaking of
stages you ever see like one of these
performers you know like Dua Lipa or uh
Ari Ariana Grande or you know
undoubtedly talented individuals but
there I saw a video and they're singing
on stage and they're having fun and then
accidentally the mic slips out of Dua
lipa's hand and it rolls into the crowd
but somehow she keeps singing with the
same amplitude and same you know
delightful modulation in other words
it's all a sham it's all she's just lip
syncing to something that she recorded
she had genuine talent but but maybe
there's and I feel like we're doing that
as a as a society like the the speakers
have dropped their microphones and we're
pretending like they're singing it they
just raise their voices and they they
won't get off the stage they can't get
off the stage it's inherent in who they
are okay so let's assume that that's
true the problem is not them
the problem is us
let's start with me the problem is me I
had this show I've got a giant audience
people say where's the portal why aren't
you doing any new shows and I'm thinking
do you know how a nerd you are to
everything you've decided that uh Jordan
Peterson Brett Weinstein Joe Rogan maybe
Brian Keating all everybody Sam Harris I
can tell you the the uh the things that
go around about every single person as
to why we can't listen to anyone who's
not on script
I have failed
Vladimir Putin has failed I'm spending
my days split between two separate
activities for the most part one is
trying to get us options
trying to figure out what it is we can
do so that if we don't agree with
zelinski Putin G Biden
and Kim we don't we don't feel that
they've got this what do we do I mean
it's sort of funny like Elon is talking
about all this stuff he's on the same
Planet the rest of our the rest of us
are the other thing that I'm doing when
I'm not trying to do physics and trying
to think about how we get out of here is
to try to figure is there any way to
wake us up and it it just doesn't seem
to be possible it seems to be that
there's some interface between Media
Tech and the human mind that until the
human mind gets the message from CNN and
in the New York Times hey we've been
lying about everything we're in great
Danger
we have the wrong leadership we need
resources completely redirected I mean
let me just be very pointed about it are
you familiar with the Anton chigur
character in No Country for Old Men
uh very very very vaguely yes okay at
some point he's about to kill Woody
Harrelson in a hotel room with a
silenced shotgun or a suppressed shock
and he asks he says may I ask you a
question always polite
if the path uh that you followed LED you
to this of what use was the path so if
you want to think about markets and you
want to think about democracy and you
want to think about the American
experiment
if the path we've LED has got us with a
79 year old commander-in-chief about 10
years almost 10 years older than the
oldest president ever in history if that
person has a five percent plus chance of
dying in any 12-month period according
to the U.S Social Security
Administration men's yeah health
statistics 79 year old U.S male if his
running mate was Kamala Harris who was
almost certainly chosen for
diversification reasons in part just the
way he announced that he was going to
make sure that his next Supreme Court
appointment was an African-American
female in NASA by the way has made an
announcement that it wants a woman and a
person of color on the moon both of
which are awesome things to have but why
make a point of it I have no that's
their mission statement so you're
talking about the Artemis program which
has in their Twitter profile again you
know the way conservatives would do this
is they'd say um you know Condoleezza
Rice uh you know is the first person to
hold this and then they'd be done with
it they wouldn't hold a week-long
celebration and talk about you know
powerful black females there's just a
difference in sort of seriousness of
purpose and and temperament we can't
talk about any of this so if we if the
path of democracy and markets have led
us to Kamala Harris being a heartbeat
away from a guy who has a five percent
chance of dying in any one year period
at age 79 in decline in cognition with
Vladimir Putin Landing shells if I
understand between 10 and 15 miles from
the Polish border which has enjoyed full
article 5 Mutual protection status since
I think 1999.
have we built the Doomsday Machine
in other words if you view all of our
interlocking agreements our markets our
laws our cultures our understandings as
a machine and we are simply the
subroutines because this machine
effectively bring Humanity to a close
not because any particular person willed
it but because we kept piling up new
instructions and we didn't check the
code that it was actually going to run
and run indefinitely exactly you know
just to finish to finish this up we've
all failed and I feel like I failed more
than any of you because if I go back to
my old stuff you know people say are you
going to sit around and say I told you
so well for sure I'm going to tell it
say I told you so because I've been on
this for years because I told you so I
also know that I failed because I got
the audience right and a huge audience I
said exactly this beware the twin nuclei
we spent two years plus under covid
which is probably something involving
Peter dajik and the Wuhan lab but we
haven't even bothered to investigate it
and and now we've got Vladimir Putin
miscalculating in Ukraine and we're sort
of chirpy about the idea that this is
going to be an exercise in masculinity
and we like zelenski's brand better than
puffy Putin emerging from covet this
these are the twin nuclei people this is
exactly what I warned you about and
because I told you so I failed more than
any of the rest of you
well you know I wanna you know I
appreciate the humility and I believe
it's sincere and I and I want to just
count in countenance the the following
uh uh subject so we I just started
teaching in person for the first time in
three years uh and it's uh it was a
little bit you know not trepidatious
anything to do with coven or anything
but just like wow do I still have it you
know I've done I I started you know
communicating via YouTube and everything
you know into the pandemic two years ago
actually I think this is our two-year
anniversary of doing podcasts together
by the way my friend
um yeah so uh so there's been you know
that was at least one good thing that
came out of covid besides staying home a
lot with my uh with my family but I'm
back in person I'm teaching students I'm
I'm enjoying the the feels of it all and
some of them are undoubtedly watching
this episode but I'm also enjoying being
with my graduate students and it
reminded me we're recruiting graduate
students we have a bumper crop of some
of the most amazing students coming to
UC San Diego to work with me and my
colleagues here and uh and the the fact
is when I start off with a new grad
student I tell him or her and I say look
what you're about to do is complicated
but it's not complex in other words a
think about a 787. it's it's very
complicated you know no one person can
build a pencil let alone a 787 dream one
but if you follow the steps the
blueprints you have the materials you
put them in together in the right order
a787 is sure to emerge on the other hand
if you tell me to make a sand pile with
exactly so many grains of sand with
exactly these dimensions that's
impossible to do because of sensitivity
and true underlying complexity or
predicting the planetary phenomenon like
the weather you need something of the
size of the Earth to predict accurately
model the climate and so I think there
is Merit to this testing idea that
you're that you're talking about because
the only way to really model the effects
maybe on society and and our Collective
conscious would be the detonation of
this device and I do I'm not advocating
it for a person I'm just saying there's
Merit to this idea because you cannot
simulate the effect of a complex process
without the complexity of the process
itself but I want to turn from that to
say really what do you think would
happen the next day and I oppose this to
Lex Friedman when I was on his show late
last year early this year actually and I
said what do you think Lux would happen
the day after we discover aliens and and
since you joined the project Galileo
with avilobe I want to get your feedback
on this too what do you think would
happen the day after we discover aliens
there
I mean it's an interesting question I I
can tell you what happened uh on
September 12th
of 2001 because everybody remembers
September 11th uh
uh who went through it
um what I was fascinated by in addition
to that was September 12th because in a
world where we're not mostly
narcissistically eager to share who we
are what we think
we didn't want to say anything most of
the very loud voices recognize that
something had happened and
that thing that had happened had grave
impact on the culture ourselves the
families affected directly you know I I
think that when Israel went through
1973's Yom Kippur War after the
brilliant victory in 1967
it was a humbling experience because
they've gotten high on their own Supply
we had gotten high on our own supplied
that there was a magical force field
protecting the United States saw almost
no action during World War II there was
a little bit of stuff from
Japanese subs and I think around Santa
Barbara I'm not quite sure but the
mainland of the U.S was basically
untouched so I think what
would happen after aliens is that either
we would actually be
transformed and and silenced and quiet
and humbled
or the change that has been brought
about by the smartphone and all of the
Innovation since September 11th
would cause us to continue to dreamwalk
that we would we would want to know if
we could get selfies we want to know
whether we could turn the aliens into an
nft
um
I think we've gone mad and I'm not
positive how to answer how a mad
civilization
would respond I can tell you that I I'm
pretty sure that if this had happened in
the 70s
it would have been very very different
we we were smarter then
you know we were being lied to but we
were being lied to lessened by fewer
people and it wasn't quite so chaotic
right
um centralized right you know so there
were a lot there are lots of things that
are much much better it's not it's not
the 70s were some Golden Era it's just
we've become
almost unforgivably psychotic
collectively I I don't know how to I
don't know how to to sugarcoat this I
feel like I am so far away from planet
Earth at the moment in my understanding
of what I'm watching what's on the line
what the odds are
you know and again I as you can see I've
clearly gone through a bunch of attempts
to estimate what are our risks until
the looking glass of the tech and the
media reflect our reality I now believe
that we are in I don't know if you've
ever seen an ant Mill where ants leave
these like pheromone Trails yeah and the
the danger is is that they'll make a
circle
and so the ants will go into a death
spiral by just following a trail that
goes infinitely and they'll die circling
you know effectively an object I feel
like we're in an ant Mill
and this particular ant
I want out let me ask you again with
I'll do tenderness and respect
um by what you know by what virtue does
one look into the equations of uh
Quantum field Theory say and from it
Divine a nuclear device in other words
where does the engineering begin and the
physics take over the the transistor is
another example we didn't really look at
the laws of quantum mechanics they said
this this filament-like act or this this
whisker of of a semiconductor with
certain impurities uh when engineered
and put in contact uh and sufficiently
close proximity behaves this way oh and
then we can explain it using
Schrodinger's equation we didn't look
into Schrodinger's equation to find the
transistor so to what extent could one
be serious about looking at String
Theory uh loop quantum gravity whatever
you want gu and look into those
equations and get off of this marble uh
you know and what what kind of walk me
through that that process sure so first
of all let's talk about the old
Discovery
um there are there were Civil War
veterans who saw action at places like
Antietam who witnessed the hydrogen bomb
in 1952. the big Discovery I think was
1932 was the neutron
and the you know the I have a living
aunt in Philadelphia who is older than
the neutron so when you make a discovery
it's not necessarily the quantum
mechanics but the
structure
of the nucleons and nuclei
um gave lease meitner a woman who did
not get enough credit for getting us
into this mess and may get us out who
knows right or blame yeah you know her
Discovery was I don't know six years
later five years later not very long
after that and then teller and ulam
figured out how to take a fission device
and turn it into a fusion uh precursor
by focusing the geometry of the the
blast from the fission device and
reflecting it back into a second stage
which actually produces the fusion it
was sort of a combination of engineering
and geometry much more than it was uh
Innovations in Quantum field Theory and
then what it did is it it sort of
it taught the physics community that
they weren't impotent that they could do
things and almost immediately after they
remembered that they were actually
capable of doing things they went back
to Quantum field Theory and basic
understanding of the universe and so you
have Shelter Island and Pocono and Old
Stone conferences which changed
everything in physics in the late 1940s
1947-48
right now what we have is we have a
theoretical physics community that is in
the same situation before the Manhattan
Project where
we've done great work the standard model
of the time was called QED but we
couldn't compute with it
and then once people like Feynman uh you
know had a chance to shine at Los Alamos
we started holding conferences where we
were really looking for Solutions and
almost immediately we were back back on
track so I have to imagine that as
horrible as the products of the
Manhattan Project were their effect on
these theoretical physics Community was
to take them out of being a cargo cult
that only got infinities
and turn them into extremely capable
Engineers so that they could go back to
being extremely capable physicists
so right now the way in which this would
work is we don't know whether we we can
get off
this planet and by that I really mean
get out of the solar system if we're
going to be here with general relativity
and that's the last word you can you
understand why Elon and uh Richard
Branson and Jeff Bezos are focused on
rocketry what we don't understand is why
rich people aren't focused on getting
rid of general relativity as a
fundamental Theory and making it an
effective Theory so that we can find out
whether the true fundamental Theory be
below it
has new possibilities and new degrees of
freedom and new opportunities for
engineering and Escape
and again the point isn't that if we go
to another planet we're not going to
bring our Madness with it it's that some
of us may not be crazy enough to blow
ourselves up and at the moment we're
talking about the lowest common
denominator and the lowest common
denominator may very well be Vladimir
Putin or Kim and that might be the sand
grain that is unpredictable that topples
the pile but do you think I mean if we
were talking on a on a zoom call or back
in you know 380 A.D and the you know
waning uh era of the Roman Empire uh I
mean are some of these things just
translation and variant they also built
a sophisticated civilization with a lot
of old you know people in charge at the
top and and plenty of uh young people at
the base of the of the societal pyramid
and uh and hungry for bread and circus
and for uh you know the the all the
accoutrements that we have we just call
them Tick Tock and Instagram uh do you
think this is a Time translation and
variant process but maybe worse by the
ratchet effect of the power awesomeness
power I don't understand what
conversation we're having again and
again forgive me because clearly I don't
I'm not a good conversationalist anymore
um
well presumably there was still uh you
know Aryan and dravidian civilization in
the subcontinent or there were Iroquois
and and and and uh Sioux precursors
during the Roman Empire and you know my
claim is is that not all our eggs were
in one basket
right but right now all of our eggs are
in one basket called Earth and you know
maybe the idea is that I should first
just limit myself to the subset of
people who find it really important that
humans have an indefinite future
I meet a lot of young people I don't
understand why do humans have to have an
indefinite future it's like perfectly
reasonable question get it away from me
you know right well they did a study a
famous study there they asked Olympic
hopefuls if they trade you know 30 years
of life expectancy for a gold medal and
50 of them said yes uh there there is
this tab but I guess what I'm saying is
you're right of course now we're playing
with fire for the first time a nuclear
fire right um so that's of course true
on the other hand it's not whole society
if if Putin were removed from the
equation if he was for God's sakes not
allowed to remain in power uh you know
just like Lee Harvey Oswald a single
individual change the world for the
worse and it's much easier for single
individuals to worsen the world than for
individuals to make it better
right so what I'm trying to say is
that's going to keep happening yeah the
key question is whether the single
individual in question
has Leverage
if you've got nuclear leverage or
biological leverage we get trouble
because those things those levers are so
levered right the amount of power
I mean literally I view this as sneaking
into God's toolbox and just rummaging
around it's self-evident to me that this
is where we are and it's self-evident to
me that there is only one plan
yeah every plan for survival involves
tasking the people who got us into this
mess because Francis Crick was a
physicist teller was a physicist ulam
was a physicist that was a geometer you
have to task the exact same people who
got you in to get you out and that may
be unfortunate you may say well you
built the Titanic and hear it sinking
go make sure that you build us some
lifeboats yeah and you're like no no I'm
not going to trust that guy he built the
Titanic look these are the only boat
Builders you've got did which part of
this here's my question Brian this is
like a four-line proof the only way out
of this conundrum assume that it's three
percent odds assume that you're playing
Roulette in either a European wheel or
an American wheel I guess the American
wheel has two green yeah um zero zero
and zero and the Europeans have one and
otherwise there's something like 36 red
and and black
things okay assume that that's the case
how many times do you get to spin this
thing before it comes up green
no one knows and not that many
yes it's unlikely but you can't keep
playing this game
all right that's the first thing next
question is if that's true give me the
total list of Escape scenarios like one
thing that you may not know that I I
only know because I've recently found
myself in circles of people who have 10
figures and up
is that a lot of very rich people are
thinking about personal escapes from
Armageddon they're not thinking about
their bunkers or yeah bunkers different
countries Yachts whatever this is
ridiculous I mean for only only in
limited situations is that a great plan
there's only one thing to do which is to
ask
how do we get ourselves diversification
so that as you point out these conserved
features of collapsing civilizations
don't take down the permanent human
Enterprise
and that's why you know I'm going to a
Bitcoin conference in Miami and I think
that the talk is supposed to be they
usually say fix the money fix the world
and I think I have a change to fix the
money leave the world
um the importance of decentralization in
space fairing if Bitcoin is a protocol
how does it work if you're
multi-planetary uh if you're in
different star systems or your kardashef
three or have infinite free energy right
yeah or do you have a different
situation whereby the point of Bitcoin
is to start working on a decentralized
option like from decentralization to
decentralization the key point of
failure
is that we're all sharing one
terrestrial surface now Bezos or Bezos I
don't know how to pronounce this last
name talks about like Gerald k O'Neill
cylinders and maybe Stanford uh Tori
where you get artificial gravity through
centripetal acceleration
um
Elon is focused on the moon not quite
sure what Branson is doing but the point
is all of these people at least have the
nub of the idea we've got to diversify
and with all that money
I don't ever want to hear about a
theoretical physicist
who isn't putting three kids through
private schools with a second home a
pension secured and the ability to check
into any Four Seasons anywhere on planet
Earth I mean this is obscene the only
people who can save us are
mathematicians and physicists
and we don't know that it's possible
it's quite possible that they could
return a final Theory and we could look
at it and say yep Einstein was right the
final Theory doesn't contain any new
options that the one faster than like
travel don't no
we don't know and until we know and
until we hold the conferences we're
stead instead held hostage to an
economic system that is is mostly there
to protect people born in like the 1940s
and 50s so that they can live out their
days pretending that they're doing
physics while they do geometric analysis
inspired by physics which they might
call String Theory or topological
Quantum field Theory or toy models or
conformal field Theory it's like no
it's now time to get back to physics
it's now time to do what Old Stone
Pocono and Shelter Island did as
conferences which is to reignite the
physics Community get the smart people
in here and here's the dumbest thing I
and I'm just embarrassed to say it but
here goes
physics built your entire economy more
or less suitably understood from biotech
to Communications to the World Wide Web
to the semiconductor the dumbest thing
in the world is money or tokens
go get us a huge pile drop it off and go
away this is the dumbest thing in the
world it's just resource
you're gonna put it down on on a gulf
stream or you're going to put it down on
a private island are you gonna whatever
you're gonna do it doesn't have anything
like the Leverage
of making sure that the people who built
your economy are cut in as wealthy
people who are independent enough to say
no Ed Whitton no David Gross no
University I'm not going to do your
stupid bidding I'm not going to bow down
to diversity equity and inclusion We're
Not Gonna We're Not Gonna adulterate
what we know how to do if it has the
opportunity to save us all
and the idea that we can't even get
resource into theoretical physics
differential geometry
is an obscenity
we built this goddamn thing and then you
we're in an agreement use Society or an
agreement which is we're not going to
let you commercialize this you're you're
frozen out of intellectual property oh
well what do we get out of the equation
oh you get institutional protection
you get academic freedom well you you
got rid of that you turned the
universities into a monstrosity so that
we can flatter our undergraduates
because what you did is you used it to
extract wealth from The Young and give
it to the old now the universities are
broken they don't work the stupid thing
is go get us a pile of money and leave
us alone and tell us to work on getting
you the hell out of here because we got
you in here that message is so simple
and it doesn't resonate it's got no
resonance
and I've given up I mean all I sit
around doing for the most part is doing
Quantum field Theory I'm giving up tons
of money
I'm not doing much of much of anything
else
because I'm I'm trying to make sure my
kids my at least my my clan has a future
and I I believe this there was no
possibility of building an atomic weapon
in 1930 because we didn't know about the
neutron
almost immediately after you had the
neutron you had Atomic power and atomic
weapons right
we don't know what physics is about to
unlock and when you look at that James
Webb Telescope and you look at it
peering out into the cosmos imagine that
it is possible that if we can get Beyond
Einstein's theory that you won't be
talking about faster than light because
space-time is an einsteinian concept
you'll be talking about something that
you have no idea what the words are
and it may be possible to visit the
universe so that you're not deciding
between Koh Samui and Tulum you know I
mean it's just it's really important to
recognize that more or less we're here
on one Speck time to go and let me just
say the last thing
I hate how how heavy and overbearing
this is but wake the hell up like you've
seen this in Ukraine you're not putting
it together because the person on
television is not telling you you're
running a three percent five percent one
percent risk something like that of
total Annihilation right now
thanks I have to inject some levity at
this point so Einstein dies Eric and
goes to shamim he goes up to heaven
and there he encounters several
individuals first one comes up to him he
says uh hello young lady what's your
what's your IQ
she says it's 156. great talk about math
physics geometry space travel wormholes
Etc then I meet somebody else what's
your IQ 130. uh oh great we can talk
about politics and life and law and
something I mean someone what's your IQ
it's a 96. oh great we can talk about
the stock market
um because yeah you're saying that this
is and no offense to my all my day
trading Bitcoin friends out there I'll
shoot my laser beam eyes at you someday
but the point being yes this should be a
problem that physics can solve and
actually you and Pia and others have
made contributions to a physicalization
of an economic uh system which is which
is rather brilliant and I'll be a topic
for another show and you have given
lectures in uh recent places like the
University of Chicago and and elsewhere
UPenn you've been all around the world
on a college tour but I want to say you
are um you're sounding dark you're
you're darker now uh then then I've
heard but let me finish let me finish
but I want to give you hope I come to
bring you hope hope and light as
President Biden just said so you don't
look at a honeybee and say could you
that's great you know the honey is sweet
could you make me a web like I really
need a web no you say I want some more
of that honey and likewise with a spider
you don't say oh make me some honey you
have a unique gift you could do science
you can do physics but you can also
reach out to literally millions around
the world you have a huge platform and
and you use it very uh with great with
great gravitas and I think it's more
than most people do and of course
they're haters oh he's a guru he's a
Svengali Let's ignore them they're
they're it's not worth discussing
however you do have an ability to
inspire and and build a Lifeboat and
provide preservers
I'm not optimistic about getting off the
planet with gu or string theory or Loop
quantum gravity in my lifetime but what
about my grandkids you're hopefully
going to be a grandfather what that was
my point about the neutron if you had a
correct theory that was a major upgrade
why wouldn't you be optimistic within a
very short window you don't know is my
point you don't know but just not
knowing is not proof that it will happen
for you know that that's why the Galileo
project is so important you see if we
can escape to the cosmos then the cosmos
can visit here right very simple if we
found out that we are being visited and
that we are being visited by something
that wants to be cryptic because it
doesn't want to be fully known
um there's precedent for that North
Sentinel Island does not probably
understand that India exists but India
claims North Sentinel Island even though
the north-centeries
don't speak any Hindi uh
or uh Tamil or whatever
we don't know what language they speak
if we can leave
they can visit and if they can visit it
means that the next iteration contains
power just the way the physics before
the neutron
had a lot less power than physics with
the neutron right
so if the Galileo project is successful
in convincing us that there is something
to visitation
then suddenly everything changes and
this is something people are embarrassed
again they will immediately compute the
social consequence of saying aliens
right and then there'll be a Roswell
thing and and everything everything
degenerates into giggles just the way
every conversating foreheads right every
conversation about sex uh you know super
important force that determines the
world but we can't talk about it without
giggling right so we have the same thing
with aliens and in that world uh you
start to understand that the odds that
we're alone in in the cosmos are are
negligible and if people
can leave
intelligence can visit and we need to
know that that's possible if somebody
told you it is possible to visit the
cosmos because Einstein isn't the last
word
you double your efforts and if they told
you you know it's much easier than
you're making it out to be and it isn't
an infinite Journey because people say
all of these idiotic things they'll say
oh I think that they're an infinite
number of problems and people have
always thought they were getting to the
end well people thought they were
getting to the end of of
InterContinental exploration and then we
found the last land mass off the north
of Siberia and we were done
right so these things do come to an end
no they do they do and but but I guess
to get back to the you know
inspirational motivational report of the
speech you have this ability and not
knowing in the future uh I I feel like
that comes with it a responsibility not
to say I failed and now I'm gonna take
my uh lashes into shuva but but instead
to say look I have a unique platform I
have a and focus entirely on inspiring
if that's what you want make me make me
happy bring me people
I need I need people I need resources
and I need them now okay Lawyers Guns
and Money well I offer to you people
here in money I I just think that Warren
zevonne belong this is the first smart
thing we've said today
send Lawyers Guns and Money but really
instead of lawyers I need differential
geometers particle theorists
and I need money that is not encumbered
and I need people not to and moan
about the fact that scientists are
comfortable and fearless and not
writing grants let's stop this grant
cycle let's get going away fine
undergraduates give me wait no Brian
give me these people and I will go back
to telling jokes playing the guitar
playing the piano I will be the sunny
host of the portal but right now
I haven't been on the air for years or
you know for over a year I'm telling you
this is the emergency
you know it's not that I'm sitting here
every second and saying we're all going
to die of covet I didn't know that
I can tell you this if you keep running
this Putin experiment and you do several
versions of it we will all die or
whatever world is left will not be the
one that you want your children to be
living in and right now if if this
doesn't get your attention I need to
separate from my audience I don't want
to entertain you
where you don't understand what's on the
line This is not Life is Beautiful while
I'm pretending that you know a
concentration camp isn't the death camp
I don't think I'm asking to pretend that
I'm asking one one of two things which I
don't think can simultaneously be true
one is that you're saying scientists
need to focus 100 on what scientists do
without the diversity BS and this thing
and that thing and bureaucratic BS and
Grant running and whatever way what was
that get out but then you're also my
friend you're also saying that like
scientists do a crappy job of selling
the best script that's ever been written
which is the scientific Enterprise and
that we don't do it and you have people
like Ed Whitton and others
if HBO wants me to do a show to get
people excited I will do you have a chef
what you have a show that's bigger than
most uh CNN broadcast I don't have a I
don't have a budget for the huge
graphics with the 3D and the projection
mapping all the stupid if that's
the stuff that excites you somebody else
handle it right now what I want to be
looking at is bundles partial
differential equations Fields operators
Hilbert spaces and I'm happy
to share what's going on with it I'm
happy to talk about what we I'm actually
not talking about you I'm not
criticizing you I'm saying that you want
to insulate scientists and give us the
academic freedom freedom that we were
promised and and I love talking to
people Brian but
yeah hold on let me let me finish please
sure I want to say I don't feel like my
other colleagues are engaging with the
public in a way that is uh is going to
further this project that you're
describing in other words they said we
sit in our in our offices or our
Laboratories and we just do what we're
supposed to we never talk to the public
we never communicate what we're doing
with their money and so of course why
should I give you more money you just
told me like I can't understand if I
could understand what you're doing it
wouldn't be worth a Nobel Prize right
Feynman uh so to what extent do we a
scientists have an obligation to have
portals of our own present company
excluded well you know you're doing I'm
doing it I'd rather be doing that stuff
when I like to take a break from
actually doing research on something or
thinking about something or building
something or whatever it is I love
talking to people I'm a social person I
like explaining what I know turning
everything into interpersonal drama or
turning everything into a market or
turning everything into a game theoretic
exercise is killing
what we knew how to do even a short time
ago so I would love to do you know half
a day's worth of uh you know actual
research equations whatever and then I'd
like to record something but if I'm
going to record something I just want to
spill into a studio and I want to tell
somebody you know in a week's time get
these things worked up as Graphics I
don't want to think about payroll I
don't want to think about human
resources I don't want to think about uh
whether or not sponsors and right well
it's like I record in this room with a
lot of glass all the audio Engineers
complain dude you should really
you know you cover your dining room in
in tarps that's going to be great for
for my family where I've taken over the
dining room and covered it in tarps I
care about two things here one I care
about inspiring people and two I care
about getting people a future I'm
looking at the people I'm trying to
inspire and I'm trying to get a future
for
and they don't even know what risk
they're in and they don't appreciate it
and they turn things into drama because
they're not strong enough to to
withstand like all the voices of you
know like if the Lancet says well this
definitely didn't come from a lab in
Wuhan well who am I yeah I guess the
Lancet said it's important to recognize
that we can inspire people if I can't
even get you to wake up and I can't even
get somebody in the government to
understand ideas have consequences
ulam and teller's ideas have great
consequences I've more or less told
people why I believe they're three
generations of fermions a year ago
I've not had a single physicist on
planet Earth say
I want to talk to you about why you say
there are three generations of fermions
I gave a reason why the world appears to
be chiral but actually is not chiral
well it appears that the weak Force beta
Decay knows it's left from its right
maximally violating of scene yeah right
and
I have not had one person
come to me and say I want to talk to you
about that you think it's credentialism
you're not in Academia you're seen as an
outsider I get I get literally it's not
me Brian it's not me it's the field when
Peter White
came out with his idea which was to
build it around the group su3 which has
the strong communicates the strong force
which is what holds nuclei together when
the protons want to run away from each
other packed in so tightly I made sure
to read what he wrote and I called him
up and he said yeah nobody's calling
now I don't have to agree with him but
at least understand what he did do and I
wanted to make absolutely sure that I
grasped the general idea
what I'm trying to tell you is I knew
that no one was going to much call Peter
no one is listening to each other
there's almost no one working on physics
I I think that that's the real statement
is that the question is what does the
community say
the community basically isn't doing
physics go to your local uh universities
physics you know high energy Theory
seminar and I challenge you to listen to
a talk
and find anything that sounds like
physics in it in general it sounds like
oh we're in Six Dimensions we've got a a
compact simple group
um and we look at the following fields
that nobody's ever seen in human history
we treat it supersymmetrically even
though we've never seen supersymmetry
we're not working
and the the economists aren't doing
economics
I I think the extent to which people
imagine that this system is continuing
to do what it once did until you
actually release new ideas you don't get
to see it's not an airport it's a cargo
call aren't you uh to react to this
statement by uh past guest on the show
Albert Einstein
Einstein said the following about two
different dynamics of of human
capability he called the and this is
from a book called The the metaphoric
Mind by Bob samples he said Albert
Einstein called the intuitive or
metaphoric mind a sacred gift he added
that the rational mind was a faithful
servant
it is a paradoxical it is paradoxical
that in the context of Modern Life we
have begun to worship the servant and to
defile the Divine oh I love it so do you
see it possible to have both signs the
intuitive metaphoric the sacred gift the
Divine and that rational
sorry go ahead he had both I mean this
is this is the interesting thing right
which is the
what was it inspiration is more
important than knowledge imagination
imagine like the center for human
imagination
right the rational people are oh you
know uh with great spirits have always
encountered uh violent opposition for
mediocre Minds in order to make huge
advances you have to be wrong in the
process
and what you find is you try to imagine
uh E.E Cummings turning in a poem
and a copy editor saying the
capitalization is off the punctuation is
wrong the grammar is non-existent yeah
no kidding it's EE Cummings great minds
have to be able to do things that are
wrong when doroc you know came up with
his equation he had numbers where a
times B wasn't B times a
and it wasn't until he realized that
they were matrices that he could make
sense of what he'd written if you can't
go through wrong you can't Advance right
and thought the positron was the proton
right that's true
um and Galileo thought the tides were
caused by the orbit of the earth not the
moon so in all of these situations
you've got this sort of copy editing
group that's always angry because it
never wins the answer stop being a copy
editor is that why you think gu is
experiencing get has experienced you
know kind of passions and opposition or
do you think it's people realize what
are you saying about that I haven't had
almost any gu conversations
well you know I was thinking about that
as you were saying we we talked
yesterday the day before you know our
mutual friend Stefan Alexander whose
birthday it was yesterday old man I
missed it yeah it's okay uh he didn't he
didn't reply to my uh video text uh but
maybe maybe he was uh having having fun
instead but you know he's got a theory
of everything he works on uh as his
latest book uh has come out you know
kind of it you know is is everything
yeah what's that he doesn't have a
theory of everything yeah he's working
on one you mentioned Peter white you
mentioned we've talked about Garrett
Lisi in other words I I don't know that
we have a dirt you know what if we have
a glut of theories of everything or our
unification geometric unification ideas
or what have you essay even you know
Shelly glasshow has one right well I
mean so5 or whatever he had right that's
u5 that's u5 that's Grand unification
yeah Grand uniform well I always say
we're putting the toe before the gut you
know because we don't have a great grand
unit but anyway some geometric you know
that will unlock Powers as you say
beyond the atom the mere atom which is
already causing so much Devastation
right so but my question is you know
maybe it's a supply problem maybe there
there are so many of these things that
how can anybody you are unique but hold
on a second hold on a second because I
have to compliment you you're a handsome
individual thank you that will always
stop talking now always stop you from
talking my beautiful brother
um but uh but the point is not
everyone's you right so not everyone's
able to to keep up with and not everyone
as I said to Lex is is as
um comatose is as um you know kind of
collegial as you that will take the time
you know our mutual friend Sabino so I
don't have time for these theories of
everything you know he'll she Wolfram
Einstein but maybe not everyone can do
what you do let's just be honest I mean
you do you have a special you know kind
of arrangement where your work is gives
you flexibility
um perhaps I you know I actually we've
never really discussed your work and I
don't want to here but but the point
being how you know how can we expect the
youngest in Professor you know down the
hall for me to get uh to get involved in
in curating and and doing a rubric on
these theories of of unification let me
just point out something that I don't
like in myself
I don't like talking over you but what
you just said is so wrong
right
I don't know how to be polite about it
you know it's not personal yeah I know
it's not perfect it's like you're
Devil's Advocate that's not what's going
on you you're pulling the conversation
gravitationally back to interpersonal
issues Sabina has enough time do I want
to call Sabina a liar no she's being
polite she's meaning to say something
else it took me about 45 minutes to get
the gist of Peter White's paper
the assistant professor you talked about
has 45 minutes to waste on all sorts of
things nobody works all the time on
their own stuff my point is nobody's
excited to look at anybody else's work
because they know nothing is going to
work now why they know nothing is going
to work I don't know but what you're
doing is you're using your show to
spread the dumbest wrong thing about
something like geometric Unity or Peter
White's Theory or Garrett lisi's anybody
in our community can read those things
for ideas right you can find the
triality of the three generations uh
Source in Garrett's E8 Theory even
though it's it's so8 that has the
triality it sort of inherits E8 inherits
this you can read about how Peter white
gets asymmetric asymmetry of the weak
Force through su2 through a wick
rotation inside complex three space
Stephen Wolfram has not actually you
know produced what I consider to be a
Theory of Everything although he's doing
his own thing and I think he should
continue to do it I'm not aware of
Shelley glashau really having a a bigger
idea than Grand unification
we all keep some track of these things
the question that you're trying to ask
me is something like what's been the
reaction to gu and what I'm telling you
is it's not what you're saying
the reaction is I've lectured in two
places because of covid one in in
Marseille in France and the other
University of Chicago at the cadenoff
center I've had perfectly polite
conversations people are interested in
various aspects but the the academic
incentive structure
the ability to be viable means that
you've got to align yourself with people
who can fund you and who can hire you
and who can give you tenure and
everyone's worried about their
reputation and nobody's worried about
physics
I don't mean absolutely nobody I had a
great conversation with for example Nima
arkani Hamed recently is going to say
you you're right what was his reaction
then I mean was he willing to engage it
or was it polite of course you know he's
very constructive you know his point is
I I learned a great deal from Nema
um Nema in my estimation
is the soul of theoretical physics right
now
because he has an ability to do
something that I think almost no one
else does which is dead reckoning
he we've lost sort of the the compass
heading from experiment because the
energy levels have gotten prohibitive
for new for new phenomena we failed for
a great deal of time so most people it
demoralized
theoretical physics lives even when Nema
and I disagree or he says something
that's critical of me
that's what real critique is what he
told me to do is hey here are the sorts
of things that you can grab the
attention of the quantum field Theory
Community now I learned something very
very important which I would love to
discuss on the show
I think one of the big problems is that
there are these three legs to the
mathematical stool which is geometry
algebra and Analysis I.E calculus
the problem with Quantum field theory is
that it grew up unbalanced it's really
almost all analysis and then we found
out very late in the day that we'd been
neglecting certain topological geometric
and algebraic things and sort of
starting in the 70s with Jim Simons for
the last 50 years
people like Ed Whitton Graham Siegel Dan
Quillen Luis alvarez-game have been
making Quantum field Theory geometric
and that's been the basic Vector of
success in the field
but what what you've come to understand
is that analysis is too brutal and crude
of a tool to have this responsibility
for carrying physics forward and I'll
give it a simple example if you have a
function like a little lump of
probability that represents where a
particle can be
and then you try to propagate that
function how do you know that the
propagation of that function isn't going
to turn the function negative in some
places or how do you know that the
function is a lump isn't going to start
moving faster than light and screw up
causality or how do you know that the
integral of the probability under that
function is going to remain 1.00
so none of those things are really
natural inside of analysis but it seems
like the geometry and the deeper
algebraic principles ensure that all of
those things are true and this goes back
to something that you know Esther perel
once said to me the great relationship
uh coach and therapist and she said the
thing about masculinity is that it's
incredibly powerful and just as fragile
in other words
a a masculine male is an incredibly
powerful person who can be damaged by a
single stray comment uh you know from a
woman and and cut low and cut to the
quick that situation is true in Quantum
field Theory which is it's incredibly
powerful but it is just as fragile and
so what Nema does which is different is
he says here are all of the restrictions
that we've learned to place on things
through
analysis and it's a very long list and
it's very brittle so anytime you want to
add something everybody has the idea of
how do we know this is going to this
isn't going to screw up what we've got
uh stuck together with masking tape and
and
paper clips and the like
in that sort of a setting his point is
here are some things that we don't know
how to do and if your thing can do that
that's the way to speak to people who
are dependent upon analysis that's an
extremely constructive form of criticism
and feedback and I've taken an audience
capture though I mean you're like it's
resolving the sociological problem of of
getting something palatable to your
analytics no no his point is he's
explaining why Quantum field theorists
have the prejudices that they do like if
you look at the Loop quantum gravity
guys and people came at a general
relativity they're much more unbalanced
in the direction of geometry what we
should have is a more balanced community
that learns how to redo Quantum field
Theory so that it works automatically to
give us a very simple example
electromagnetism is four equations if
you do it the way Maxwell did through
pure analysis but if you do it through
geometry geometry and forces two out of
the four so you don't even have to
mention them so it cuts down the number
of equations to two and then those two B
become unified so really there's only
one Maxwell equation if you if you
understand the geometry
what we're doing currently in Quantum
field theory is it's a giant grab bag of
mostly analytic techniques
and that's why the quantum field Theory
Community has this sort of extreme
I don't know what to call it exactly
they're very guarded because it's sort
of like
they've built a hot rod that can fall
apart in an instant and has is very
finicky and if we built something more
robust I think the field would be much
more intellectually healthy so I've
learned a lot by talking to I don't know
just spoke to Alan Guth at MIT when I
visited so I'm talking to great people
people are being extremely positive
polite constructive what you see online
is you got you've got a different class
and caliber of people mostly people
who've left the field and sort of you
know try to score points by bitching and
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
listen to the top people in the world
about what what's the best way of
communicating with the with the
community because I think this is the
world's most important community
you think it's um in the last say 15
minutes that we have I mean do you think
it's not unexpected I mean the famous
you know Thomas kuhn's structure of
Scientific Revolution the sort of you
know predicated on uh periods of
normalcy uh you know supplanted by
periods of crisis when facts don't agree
with uh with with uh
um you know kind of the accepted
Paradigm and that leads to so-called
paradigm shift but these he said can
last for decades Generations you know
lifetimes and you know I wonder if
layering in you know it's like options
pricing right I mean options are you
know you you have to get the price
Direction and the time scale right so
I'm wondering if if if we're on balance
um not really capable of doing such a
thing in physics where you know the
direction the field should take and
you're in the time scale that's
commensurate with tenure with somebody's
got to step in and rescue the community
from itself
and it has to be somebody with money and
and to be honest I think Bezos was a
physics major at Princeton
or at least he was starting out in that
direction Elon Musk was one at the
University of Pennsylvania Jim Simons
the most successful hedge fund manager
in the world and has given a lot like
we're too tied to what doesn't work
if you think about String Theory String
Theory mopped up most of the best Minds
uh during our time
and it doesn't work
and I don't when I say it doesn't work I
don't mean that we didn't learn anything
from it it wasn't inspiring I don't mean
that we should throw away the ideas I
don't mean it won't eventually be part
of something but it doesn't work to find
the theories we need and if you can't
say that which is terrifying I mean you
know who am I to say that Ed Whitton
doesn't know what he's doing but Ed
witton as a leader of the field as
opposed to a researcher took way too
many resources in one particular
direction wasn't able to make his bid
and right now
those very wealthy people need to save
this field and they need to build Fu
money into the field so that individuals
don't have to knuckle under Brian here's
my problem
I don't want to keep saying this in most
of what I do
I don't like which is correcting people
gu is doing fine
it is being listened to I'm in
constructive conversations I wanna
I want to speed it up
I want to have conversations that I need
to be having we need to be having
conferences we need to be
you know having multiple I don't want to
take all the resources that were in
strings and become the same thing for GU
I want us to spread out get active get
excited and it's time to save everybody
else because they can't save themselves
everyone else is Frozen in place turning
on the news to find out whether or not
they've got a new virus or a nuclear
threat from Eastern Europe it's crazy so
when we look at you know these these
challenges I think you know as Nema said
in an interview I read recently that you
know it's sort of hardwired into
physicist DNA to be reductionist I
wonder if you could have you know one
piece of data one datum I shall we say
what would be most dispositive you know
for any Theory not just to you but what
would be the key you know piece of data
that could be crucial and discriminating
between the possibilities between all
these different models is there such a
thing I can tell you what particles I
think are left to find
in terms of their signatures and it's
funny people always say well what what
Mass what energy which is like the one
bit that you need Quantum field Theory
to do because you have to compute the
radiative corrections and there are a
bunch of things I don't know how to do
yet and maybe I can get there at age 56
maybe I can't but there are certainly
particle predictions that come out of gu
that would immediately say okay well he
told us all these they're they're in
that draft but that's the dumb version
of it the smart version of it is totally
different it's not a question about oh
Theory and experiment in the scientific
method it's like
look at what is it 26 27 28 parameters
free parameters in the standard model
that's the ugliness that no one wants to
deal with who's gotten involved in
geometric physics they don't want to
take on three generations with the ckm
Matrix with random entries and a pmns
matrix and Higgs couplings that
determine the shape of the Mexican hat
potential all that stuff is artificial
with gu what I'm starting to do with gu
is to say oh I I see you didn't get why
I'm claiming there are three generations
that are observed inside of this
geometry you didn't understand why I'm
I'm claiming the Higgs field makes sense
as opposed to as an artificial get out
of jail free card for the for the mass
generation the real question is do you
not understand that the key issue is
naturality what we have is a workable
theory that is extremely unnatural it's
in a natural language there are natural
components the Yang Mills component is
very natural the Dirac component is very
natural the internal quantum number is
incredibly unnatural the Higgs potential
incredibly unnatural the number of
generations incredibly unnatural the
chirality knowing left from right
incredibly unnatural but gu offers is a
huge number of explanations of why this
unnatural structure is not only natural
but gorgeous so in the last couple of
minutes that we have left um well you
mentioned you're going to some Bitcoin
conference uh has that has your thinking
evolved on bitcoin fixing this where
this could be anything from any nuclei I
love those guys I know you guys one of
the reasons is that we fought we went
through this whole sort of interpersonal
drama stupidity and then they got kicked
in the teeth when the price of Bitcoin
relative to Fiat went down
and they realized that I wasn't their
enemy I was their friend I mean I'm not
I'm not one of them I'm not putting on
the laser eyes all that kind of stuff
but I want them to be the big dogs at
least they're excited about life they're
excited about something that's new a lot
of them have made money and sooner or
later you know one of the things I took
this guy Robert Breedlove who's one of
the big Bitcoin guys uh to the
University of Chicago I wanted to show
him what happens when you look at
academic economics uh from the point of
view of a different academic subject
any time these guys want to they can
start endowing chairs in universities to
make sure that professors are present
who can say no you know it's interesting
like why is nobody endowing an
anti-wokenness chair people are bitching
about wokeness
but you could actually use money
to stop the persecution of scientists
inside of universities by their woke
colleagues from the humanities well you
typically can't you know you as a donor
you know determine who gets a particular
job and yeah
with money at a university in fact some
of the most disreputable people in the
world have tried to launder their
reputations by contributing to
universities I can think of a particular
Center in a particular University not
that you could yeah yeah
um not I wasn't thinking about Jeff
Epstein in the media lab but thank you
for asking the the the
um
what I'm trying to say is
we're acting powerless and we're acting
like we have an infinite amount of time
and we don't what we need is we need a
tiny number of the world's smartest
richest people
to wake up and recognize you're all
going to die and you're not going to be
able to take that with you you could at
least figure out how to maybe save all
of humanity in your descendants because
there's a huge thank you for whoever it
is that actually steps up to the plight
I don't know what they're doing we we've
produced the wrong Elite for sure well
sir in the remaining few minutes I want
to open the floor to questions from you
no I want to ask you uh what you're
excited about not to be you know
pollyannaish about it we did talk a lot
about
let's let's phrase it like this is it
okay for me to ask you coping strategies
like what what are you doing to oh take
care of yourself I'm really excited
strangely about non-standard Blues
progressions so I've been working with
stormy Monday uh let's go get stoned
um the song drown in my own tears
uh train kept a rolling all night long
and trying to understand why
non-standard Blues progressions are so
brilliant why the brain doesn't really
notice uh how ingenious they are so
that's been something I've been super
excited about I just got a new spark
mini amplifier from positive grid they
sent me so now I can walk around with my
electric guitar carrying a tiny amp with
huge sound which is greatly fun I'm
spending a tremendous amount of time
with your colleague and my son Zev who
is on fire about history philosophy
Linguistics physics differential
geometry and just to see life through
the 16 year old eyes he's kicking my ass
in all sorts of things uh it's just one
of the great feelings watching my
daughter grow and trying to think about
my golden retriever and my wife after
the kids have gone you know dreaming
about travel and maybe getting back to
Hindi in Russian and Turkish and
languages that I love so I'm still very
much invested in you know food song
Friends music it's the desire to save
all these things that leads to the
heaviness it's like I love I love what
we have so much and I want to share it I
don't know how to say I can't watch
everything I care about being balanced
on a pole
um with a cat in a in a hat you know
keeping it on its nose it's just like I
end up as the fish because I care about
all of the things that are at risk yeah
it's true as they say you know if I have
committed one crime it's that I love too
much and obviously this this is all we
have I'm convinced forever but uh but
maybe maybe Avi in the Galileo project
and other technologies will prove us
wrong but uh but for now I want to thank
you I want to wish you a happy spring
happy April Fool's Day and a solemn
holiday observed with uh many many
different uh Traditions around the world
let me just say something be before you
let me go it's been great watching uh
you grow your channel grow your presence
um and take on all the stuff you know
with the dad jokes uh
as the adult in the room and uh thank
you for also bringing the perspective of
the experimentalist I think that you
know you say this and we don't hear you
enough and you say isn't it interesting
that we keep talking to the
the theorists in physics who sort of
scratched that itch where we don't
believe in God what is this place and
what are we and and what is the cosmos
in the universe and I do think that I'm
going to be looking for what you're up
to with the the telescopes uh in Chile
uh anything you're you're telling me
about what's going on at the South Pole
Cosmic inflation uh the new James Webb
Telescope and I think focusing us
more on experimental physics physics is
something that is going to be part of
what comes next and I think it's an
absolutely important thing that we start
balancing some of the madness of
theoretical physics with some of the
practicality of the people who actually
prove that these things are true real
and have consequence so thanks I
appreciate that and from what I'm
looking forward to it's really teaching
teaching is a kind of a gift to the
Future to your future self to the future
of humanity I'm really enjoying it more
than I ever did and that's you know kind
of all these weird things like being on
a commercial airliner you know like I
enjoy it uh it's weird to say but
especially being back with my students
and teaching in person there's no
replacement and I'm more bullish you
know if you ask me during covid when we
were talking about the academic Hunger
Games two years ago for the first time
on this channel we rolled out that
little uh Legend domain or what is it
called portmandu uh I I wouldn't have
thought that Academia could really
survive and uh and yet I I think I think
it will because of there's some richness
that's irreducible in the in the
beautiful world of Academia that
involves people convening to discuss
ideas and it still happens and I'm still
delighted and honored to have people
like you to share it with so we have the
greatest diversity equity and inclusion
program on Earth and it's called passion
and Merit and it's open to one and all
absolutely well thank you my brother and
uh it's good to see you it's good to see
you too be well Brad we'll catch up
again soon